good morning believe nation today's
messages try to be different over to you
Jimmy Iovine and I would also say try to
be unique and try to be different
everybody today if you put on like
alternative radio the guitars sound
exactly the same you know it's like it's
like people blame the record companies
for that was gonna to do with the record
company it's got to do with the lack of
imagination that we're going through
right now in certain areas of music and
kids think that they're supposed to copy
things on television or on the Internet
and that's how they're gonna get
successful well the best way to be
successful is to have it influence you
or make up your own thing so I'm a big
believer modeling success I think you
can learn a lot from other people I
think whatever problem that you have
faced somebody else has already faced
before and by trying to come up with
every unique thing yourself that's a
recipe for failure and it's something
that I learned early on in my career as
an entrepreneur failing and failing and
failing and then I realized hey I'm not
the first kind of try to do this before
and I modeled the success of Bill Gates
in particular to help build my software
company up I think though the part of
the story that maybe I don't talk enough
about is that in the modeling of the
success you need to make it your own you
need to apply the knowledge that worked
for them to your situation and so you
know Bill Gates's partnership strategy
helped skyrocket my business I didn't do
the exact same thing as him I took that
idea of partnering and looked at okay
who can i partner with in my industry
because it wasn't the exact same
industry I remember when I was training
with my media agency and they were
training me to be a better speaker and
every week I'd get assignments from her
media coach Janie every week she gave me
assignments and they always felt a
little bit off to me
they were always they always stretched
myself they always push my boundaries
but but what she asked me to do never
felt quite right
I always had to shift it to make it my
own
and she had all the knowledge you know
she'd work with tons of people before
she had improved a lot of people before
and the message has given me was was
really good just not perfect for me I
needed to I needed to take that
knowledge and then make it my own
same thing for for Steve who ran the
agency he would give me feedback and
tips on how to get better and give me
assignments that also never felt fully
me and I did them anyway and and through
that process
I learned what I liked and what I didn't
like and then made my own thing and I
think that's the thing at first you can
copy you can copy to understand how
something is done you can copy to get
some knowledge but then you got to twist
it to make it your own because people
don't want just a copy of somebody else
right there's a lot of people who try to
copy what I'm doing on my You Tube
channel and it's awesome I don't care
about them people keep notifying me to
say hey Evan this person copied you is
like great I'm not looking I'm not
looking back because you can't you can't
be a better Evan than than Evan I'm
looking forward to what else I can do to
be different and continue to make a mark
and so I think that's such an important
part of Mahlon success is that if you
watch these videos and you learn
something from them you can't just do
exactly what they're doing
you've got to take it and make it your
own and part of what I love about the
videos and I stress a lot on the channel
is that I don't want you to be Steve
Jobs or be Bill Gates or be Oprah
Winfrey I want you to take pieces of
them to make you the best version of
yourself that's the point that's why I
can learn from someone like Kanye or
someone like Donald Trump even though
they have personalities that rub people
a lot the wrong way and I've seen I want
you to be Kanye or be Trump or be these
characters but there's a lot you can
learn from them and a lot of people
can't pull out the knowledge in the end
the and the genius from sometimes the
craziness and it's great cuz I'm not
saying be Kanye I'm saying
learn from Kanye to be the best version
of yourself and so whatever knowledge is
out there it's not gonna work exactly
just by copying it it's gonna be by
modifying it to fit you
and allow you to be the best version of
your self so the question that ate today
is I want to know one thing you've
modeled from somebody else and twisted
it and molded it to be your own thing
and I've had success with it I think it
could be a really helpful experience for
others to read about your success and
get some ideas on how they could do it
themselves leaving the comments below
I'm really curious to find out thank you
guys so much for watching have an
amazing day you continue to believe and
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of an espresso